if you're a fan of Elon Musk and you're
looking for ways to solve big problems
never give up and ignore the critics in
this video is for you you decided to
build a space company why on earth would
someone do that got that question a lot
extrude that poor Forge had to work that
would have been it we would have not had
the resources to mount a fifth you
couldn't have gone on at that point yes
death would have been I think inevitable
critics say you can't do this your
answer to them is we've done it
what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see explode
out into the world I started the mentor
me series to try to hang on people
who've done a lot more than us and my
spending a little bit more time with
them hopefully some of their beliefs
their mindsets their way of thinking
seeps into us to help us become the best
version of ourselves so today we're
gonna learn from one of the best Elon
Musk and his amazing journey mentor me
Elon
[Music]
you
t-minus 20 seconds per stage 2 tanks
pressing for flight my computer has to
control the vehicle do you see anything
on the sensors that's a problem I'll say
go for launch
[Music]
[Applause]
it's going baby come on baby let's go
all right say she got come on
[Music]
[Applause]
sharings
the first stage they seemed begin a
series of three burns to head back
towards Cape Canaveral okay there's okay
this is bad
[Music]
but mostly that
[Music]
it's done again it's not like an
explosion
look at this way it's just sitting there
looking what
holy smokes man
[Applause]
it's kind of amazing that this window of
opportunity is open for life to go
beyond Earth and we just don't know how
long that windows gonna be open the
thing that gets me most fired up is up
creating the self-sustaining
civilization on Mars would be the
greatest adventure ever ever in human
history it would be so exciting to wake
up in the morning and think that that's
that's what's happening
all right kicking ass off rule number
one aim to solve big problems it made
some money from the sale of PayPal you
decided to build a space company why on
earth would someone do that got that
question a lot that's true we people -
did you hear the joke about the guy who
made a small fortune in the space
industry yeah obviously started with a
large one is the punchline and I tell
people I was trying to figure out the
fastest way to turn a large fortune into
a small one and they'd look at me like I
was he serious and you are so it it was
a close call when things almost didn't
work out because we came very close to
failure but we managed to get through
that point in 2008 the the goal of
SpaceX is to try to advance rocket
technology and in particular to try to
crack a problem that I think is vital
for Humanity to become a spacefaring
civilization which is to have it rapidly
and fully reusable rocket would humanity
become a spacefaring civilization so
that was a dream of yours and a way from
a young age or like you've dreamed of
Mars and Beyond um I made I did build
rockets when I was a kid but I didn't
think I'd be involved in this it was
really more from the standpoint of what
are the things that need to happen in
order for the future to be an exciting
and inspiring one and I really I don't
think there's a fundamental difference
if you sort of look into the future
between a humanity that is but a
spacefaring civilization that's out
there exploring the Stars on multiple
planets and I think that's really
exciting and
compared with with one where we have
forever confined to us until at some
eventual extinction event musk decided
that the only way to get an affordable
rocket was to build it himself
and he started SpaceX I thought to be
coming into the rocket business not
knowing anything about rockets not
having ever built anything I mean I
would have to be insane if I thought the
odds are in my favor
why even begin when something is
important enough you do it even though
flowers are not in your favor how much
of your personal fortune have you poured
into this one hundred million dollars a
hundred million dollars into something
that you did not believe would work at
the beginning yes next up at number two
is learn your craft how did you get the
expertise to be the chief technology
officer of a rocket ship company well I
do have a physics background that's
helpful as a foundation and then I read
a lot of books and talk to a lot of a
lot of smart people you're self-taught
yeah well itself toward yes meaning I
didn't I don't have an aerospace degree
so how did you go about acquiring the
knowledge well I like said I had read a
lot of books talked a lot of people and
and have a great team moving down the
number three is never give up four years
after starting SpaceX rolled out its
first rocket an unmanned booster called
the Falcon one has cleared the tower but
the first three test flights failed to
reach orbit we are hearing from the
launch control center that there has
been an anomaly on the vehicle when you
had that third failure in a row did you
think I need to pack this in why not
I don't ever give up
I mean I'd have to be dead or completely
incapacitated it turned out that the
third failure was caused by a two-second
glitch in the timing eight weeks later
must bet the company on another flight
and this time around everything worked
perfect if that fourth launch hadn't
worked that would have been it we would
have not had the resources to mount a
fifth you couldn't have gone on at that
point yes death would have been I think
inevitable because we did not have the
resources to to mount a fifth launch
this is a tricky business tricky yeah
yeah I wish it wasn't so hard
[Music]
coming in at number four is innovate so
you've somehow slash the cost of
building a rocket by 75% depending on
how you calculate it
how on earth have you done that enough
so it has been doing the spheres how
have you done this we've made
significant advances in the technology
of the airframe the engines the
electronics and the launch operation I
mean it there's a long list of
innovations that they would come with
they're that they're a little difficult
to communicate in this talk but because
you could still get copied right but I
mean you haven't patented this stuff
it's really annoying you don't have this
you think it's more dangerous to patent
than not about it since our primary
competitors are national governments the
possibility of patents is questionable
the thing about Rockets is that they're
all expendable oral rockets that fly
today are fully expendable the Space
Shuttle was an attempt at a reusable
rocket but even the main tank of the
space shuttle was thrown away every time
and the parts that were reusable took a
10,000 person group nine months to
refurbish for flight so the Space
Shuttle ended up costing a billion
dollars per flight obviously that that
doesn't work very well
what just happened there we just saw
something
that's right so it's important that the
rocket stages be able to come back to be
able to return to the launch site and be
ready to launch a game within a matter
of hours Wow yeah reusable rocket yes
and and so what so that's what a lot
people don't realize is the cost of the
fuel of the propellant is very small
it's much like on a jet so the cost of
the of the propellant is about 0.3% of
the cost of the rocket so it's possible
to achieve let's say roughly a hundred
fold improvement in the cost of space
flight if you can effectively reuse the
rocket but that's why it's so important
every mode of transport that we use
whether it's Planes Trains automobiles
pipes courses is reusable but not
rockets so we must solve this problem in
order to become a spacefaring
civilization this is actually amazing
when you think about it you've never
seen this before
a rocket blasting off and then yes that
rocket is about the size of a 12 story
building
[Applause]
[Music]
so now it's it's hovering at about 40
meters and it's constantly adjusting the
angle of the pitch in Euro of the main
engine and maintaining role with the
coal gas thrusters
okay next up at number five is ignore
the critics there are people who have
been in the rocketry business for
decades yeah who say about you that you
don't know what you don't know well I
suppose that's true of anyone how can
anyone know what they don't know but
critics say you can't do this your
answer to them is we've done it he's
done it in partnership with NASA which
has given SpaceX technical advice and a
contract worth up to one point six
billion dollars mostly for 12 cargo
flights to the space station but
SpaceX's lack of experience bothers some
NASA legends like Apollo astronauts Neil
Armstrong and Gene Cernan they've
testified to Congress that the Obama
administration's drive to commercialize
space could compromise safety and
eventually cost the taxpayers now it's a
time to overrule this administration's
pledge to mediocrity you know there are
American heroes who don't like this idea
the alarm strong gene cernan have both
testified against commercial spaceflight
in the way that you're developing it and
I wonder what you think of that I was
very sad to see that because those guys
are yeah you know those guys are heroes
of mine so it's really tough you know I
wish they would come and visit and see
the hardware that we're doing here and
then I think that would change their
mind
they inspired you to do this didn't they
yes
and to see them casting stones in your
direction it's difficult
did you expect them to cheer you on so
they hoping it would what are you trying
to prove to them what I'm trying to do
is to make a significant difference in
in spaceflight end and help make
spaceflight accessible to to almost
anyone and I would vote for as much
support in that direction as we as weak
University and finally number six is
create history that's not a typo
although it is aspirational so we've
we've already started building the
system the tooling for the main tanks is
has been ordered the facility is being
built we will start construction the
first ship around the second quarter of
next year so in about six to nine months
we should start building the first ship
I feel fairly confident that we can
complete the ship and be ready for a
launch in about five years five years
seems like a long time today
[Music]
and I the the area under the curve of
resources over that period of time
should enable this time frame to you met
but if not this time frame I think
pretty soon thereafter now but that's
that's how that's our goal is to try to
make the 2022 Maas rendezvous the birth
mars synchronization happens roughly
every two years so every two years
there's an opportunity for just to fly
to Mars so then in 2024 we want to try
to fly for ships two of which would be
crude and to 2002 to occur the goal of
of the of these initial missions is to
is to find the best source of water
that's for the first mission and then
the second mission the goal is to build
the the propellant plant so we should
with particularly with six ships there
have plenty of landed mass to construct
the propellant Depot which will consist
of a large array of solar panels very
large array and then everything
necessary to mine and refine water and
then draw the co2 out of the atmosphere
and then create and store deep fry or
ch4 and or to then build up the base
starting with one one ship then multiple
ships and start building out the city
then making the city bigger even bigger
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and yeah and over time terraforming was
and making it really a nice place to be
Thanks
I really thank you guys so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed I'd love to
know what did you take from this video
that had the biggest impact on you that
you're going to apply somehow in your
life your business leave incomes below
I'm really curious to find out I also
want to give a quick chatter to
practical psychology he picked up a copy
of my book you're one word and did a
review on his YouTube channel which
recently passed 1 million subscribers
Congrats man thank you for all the
support I'm so glad you enjoyed the book
and I appreciate the review in this
video we're gonna be reviewing the book
your one-word by Evan Carmichael I'll
teach you how you can increase your
success by finding a single word that
describes yourself and I'll find mine in
the process so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever you're on where it is much love
I'll see you soon
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core value is that that people need
passion and not one drop of most
self-worth depends on Europe it's
something Samia
I don't ever give up I'd have to be
dead or completely incapacitated hey
believe nation if you want to see my
all-time favorite top ten rows of
success I have a very special secret
video for you these are the individual
clips that I have personally learned the
most from and applied to my life and my
business check the link in description
for details